in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
Nicholas and Rebecca are with us hey
guys how are you
Heidi doing great Dave welcome with some
honor to have you where do you live
we are from winter garden just outside
our land Oh Florida absolutely very cool
well it's an honor to have you thank you
for being here and you're here to do
your debt-free scream yes we are and how
much debt have you paid off one hundred
and thirty six thousand and thirty
months way to go excellent and what kind
of range of income during those time uh
front of starting out at about eighty
five up to 115 Wow excellent cool what
do you guys do for a living I'm a
financial analyst and I'm a Marine Corps
veteran now I stay home with our son
Jackson very cool good excellent and who
you financial analyst for Lockheed
Martin Oh excellent good good for you
great great gig so what kind of debt was
the hundred and thirty six thousand
everything we had three motorcycles two
new cars student loans personal loan
401k loan credit cards you name it we
were normal and a financial analyst did
that ha
a financial degree does not make you
smart in your personal life for sure you
know what I have a finance degree too
and they don't teach you squat about
this stuff no they teach us all the
other stuff that you use everyday at
work but it has nothing to do with
personal finance it really does in the
number of people that I know that are
CPAs and financial analysts and
financial advisers that are broke it's
amazing so oh my the Cobblers kids have
no shoes right that's it oh my goodness
so what happened thirty months ago
thirty months ago I had a long commute
back and forth to school and I happened
to come across your show on the radio
and heard people making less than us and
having more debt than us paying it off
quick so started thinking read the Total
Money Makeover and then it was on to me
trying to convince Rebecca
mrs. smartypants Financial Analysts
that's a full on title right there
mrs. smartypants Financial Analysts okay
so how did miss the smartypants figure
out that she's going to read the book
Nik actually started convincing me by
you know we could pay off this we could
pay off our car and I actually said why
would we ever want to pay off our car we
will always have a car payment and
looking back I feel like so silly oh
that's that will you're just normal yeah
he was reading every book that you have
ever made Dave and every day it saved so
I read this today so I read this today
so I read this today and then he said
I'm gonna enroll us in Financial Peace
University and I said okay let's do it
yeah so far we got on a budget and it'll
shut you up I'll go to the class
otherwise you're gonna read all these
books to me yeah so I'm interested
because your brain works like mine works
with a similar academic background so
all kidding aside you you um we do not
were not taught this stuff we establish
that you and I were not taught this
stuff in our formal education and so he
finds this crazy guy on the radio and
it's real easy I would it would be
difficult for me to he take financial
for my wife start coming and start
telling me something financial even
before I was quote Dave Ramsey you know
unquote but the when you went into that
class what was your attitude when you
started and what how was the process
your mind went through Rebecca as you're
going through the first couple of
classes um now it's hard to remember
that far back do you remember me saying
anything I've just just the budget how
everything kind of made sense the baby
steps made did you not go in with some
kind of uh like an intellectual
resistance when he just said the budget
i I do budgets yeah but I do million
dollar budget
yeah it's a lot harder to do hundreds of
dollar budgets you know yeah well when
it you say no to you you know and when
Nick mate you know we sat down in one of
those first classes from Financial Peace
University homework and it was do a zero
based budget and we fought a lot during
the first few months we didn't get a
good budget till probably month six yeah
we say three but I had another three for
my my smarty pants nest so so what was
the or were the arguments about this is
good
the biggest one was getting organized
like well Rebecca's the nerd and her
spreadsheets color cool color-coded and
all that just didn't a my client already
thinks they're awesome but my husband he
doesn't like them hmm
so that you know that hurt my pride too
yeah so now you got to use these
primitive forms uh-huh yeah instead of a
spreadsheet yeah and he wanted to see
you know every nickel and dime which was
which was right yeah and a lot of times
I was like well I don't know I don't
know and so we had to learn to tell our
money where to go okay definitely
but circling back around I'm not trying
to beat a dead horse but I'm really
interested I'm truly intrigued because
I'm trying to think how my mind would
work in this situation because the first
thing I have is cynicism about anybody
in the money world right that first that
shield goes up first but I think I would
have gone into the class with some
intellectual pride meaning like I know
what this class is like primitive you
know because it is pretty straight of
and I wondered if you had that kind of a
resistance well I didn't tell anybody I
was in finance because I should know
better I kept that secret to myself but
little shame yeah um I really looked at
it as you know they don't teach you how
to take care of yourself okay so we got
to get the skill okay you were more
practical then good okay you approached
it better than I would have okay cool
very good good good good so well now
that you've done it a hundred and thirty
six thousand dollars it's official you
are the smartypants family now you've
done it now tell people what is the
secret to paying off one hundred thirty
six thousand dollars in 30 months I
think it's getting on the same page
which you know can take some effort but
it really came down for me we want to
change our family tree yeah having the
same goals for the future we want to to
teach our son Jackson the right way to
handle money that we didn't know and you
know one of your things that you say all
the time is give Total Money Makeover as
a wedding gift for the $50 bill inside
just in case you know they get mad and
we've given that to three different
wedding
and my little brother when he moved out
on his own and has anybody found the 50
I always tuck it in about two chapters
and just to see if they're gonna
actually look I checked on the last
wedding I gave it to I said hey did you
ever get my wedding gift and she was
like yeah I'm reading it and I said did
you get the $50 bill and she goes oh
yeah okay good I didn't know how old is
Jackson he's 18 months okay so in the
middle of this process two and a half
years
yeah year and a half ago here comes
Jackson that had that out of the
motivation then the whole there's
something noble about changing your
family tree that you'll do that you'll
do something for him you wouldn't do for
yourself right fight through the budget
fights get on the same page bust it what
did you sell anything oh we did we sold
two brand-new cars that we had bought
three motorcycles loan had to garage
sales so we went gazelle and text
everything that wasn't nailed down so
what were the cars what kind of cars uh
two Volkswagens two Volkswagen the
diesels like the cellos or whatever yeah
we're like the worst car people wreck I
and then and then and what are you
driving now we have a 2004 mercury with
125,000 miles on it it makes funny
noises and hey and I love it
it's paid for that's okay for car yeah
well now you make 115 thousand a year
you got no debt you can save up and get
you a decent car definitely very well
done congratulations you two
very well done thanks for being real cuz
this stuff's hard isn't it yes but I
mean six months of fights yeah that's
real easy concepts and we've tried so
many times to tell different circles of
influence that we're in and and when
we're saying it we're like gosh this is
such common it's so hard for people to
follow yeah because we're all a little
bit of a smarty pants no problem
Shirin said that's a great line very
well done all right Nicholas and Rebecca
and Jackson one hundred and thirty six
thousand dollars paid off in 30 months
making 85 to 115 count it down let's
hear a debt free scream three two why
to get free
yeah that little boys family tree has
changed that really happened that is
awesome
that's how you do it folks right there
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show you can
do this you know that really is a
message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income or five hundred thousand dollar
intercom